the environmental movement has presented
a very negative vision of what we need
to do and it's always the things that we
have to stop doing but I think the other
side of that coin is that we can really
improve our quality of life if we do
things differently Robert Costanza is
one of the founders of the field of
ecological economics it's not in any way
assured that the future will be
sustainable and desirable but unless we
focus on trying to create that future we
will we will obviously never never
happen so we don't know what's really
possible and we won't know what's
possible - until we've tried we don't
want to sustain something that's bad on
the other hand we don't want to have
something that's desirable that doesn't
last so we want something that really is
is both of those things that we can
sustain into the future but also is is
desirable and I think our current system
is is neither of those things
it's neither sustainable or desirable
and so we need to to create a new
economy a new new system that that can
sustain itself that can maintain that
can prevent damaging the ecological
life-support system beyond its ability
to repair itself and yet can allow human
human flourishing human prosperity
within those biophysical constraints and
you know history has shown that the best
way to achieve positive results is to
first envision them you have to create a
positive vision in order to have any
chance of achieving it so if we if we
remain mired in pessimism and defeatism
then we will be defeated but if we
create a positive vision and so here's
what we really want then then at least
we have the possibility of finding the
path to get us there and I think
positive visions are much more
motivating for people than than negative
visions I think that's been part of the
problem with the environment
that negative visions are not motivating
in the end they can help to solve
immediate problems you know to stop
doing something that's really bad right
now but they can't helped us to solve
the larger term longer term kinds of
problems of how do we really change our
society in order to achieve these these
goals a democratic society needs to
create a shared vision of where it wants
to go what what the goals are I think
we've ignored that part of it you know
since the founding fathers came up with
our original vision and we don't live in
an empty world anymore which was the
situation in 1776 when we had a lot of
frontier and when natural capital and
social capital were not the limiting
factors so we need to re-envision you
know what our goals are in this new
context and in fact that process of
envisioning needs to be an ongoing
process I think we have the technology
now to actually begin to start to do
that you know we have a global
conversation in real time is actually
possible for the first time in human
history so there's a lot of interesting
psychological research recently about
the psychology of happiness the science
of happiness what actually does
contribute to people's sense of
well-being and what they're finding very
clearly is that material consumption
only contributes up to a certain fairly
low threshold and beyond that it's other
things it's your interactions with your
friends and family it's your
interactions with nature that that
contribute to increasing your well-being
and in fact studies show that people who
are more materialistically oriented
actually suffer from higher rates of
both mental and physical illness so it's
not making people better off to consume
more even though that's the message
we're getting from from advertising you
know on a daily basis a barrage of of
the message that you know if you consume
a certain product you'll be happier in
fact the reality is is it's just the
reverse that the more we focus on those
material consumption kinds of options
for improving happiness the worse off we
are obviously there's a there's a real
balance here you know you need a certain
amount of material consumption to
survive you need food
you need transportation we need all of
those things but I think we focus far
too much on that aspect of our the
contributions to to well-being and we
need to create a better balance you know
among the various things that do
contribute to our well-being the
transition from the current system to a
more sustainable positive future will be
difficult but not impossible
we have a lot invested in the current
system
and making the transition to some other
system then requires more than just you
know wanting to do it more than just
because there's a lot of inertia and
investment to overcome one of the
lessons I think from that is that the
worst thing you can do when when trying
to help an addict overcome their
addiction is tell them that they're
doing the wrong thing and they're you
know they have to stop and you know that
immediately causes a defensive reaction
I think that's exactly what we've done
with the environmental message
particularly climate change you know
that this is something that's that's
wrong and we have to stop and we have to
you know reduce our consumption etc but
that's the I think they're the wrong way
to frame it because one way to overcome
that is to say here's you know it's it's
not you're not doing the wrong thing but
here's something better that that we
could be doing that would improve the
situation and unless you have that
positive vision out there for what would
happen after the addiction is overcome
then it's very difficult to get any
movement at all professor Costanza is
founder and editor-in-chief of the
journal solutions solutions encourages
dialogue and consensus building to solve
environmental social and political
problems we created a new journal slash
website that's called solutions that's
focused on building the shared vision on
having a discussion a dialogue about
what those integrated solutions might be
and all solutions really affect many
parts of life you can't just have a
technical solution that's going to going
to solve a problem without having other
other impacts so we need to think about
how these things are interconnected and
what real solutions might be and what
are real what are
oles are Peter Victor has an interesting
book out called managing without growth
and he asked just this question what
would a sustainable economy look like
could we have a an economy that was not
growing in GDP terms but that was
actually improving in in quality of life
terms and he he lists a number of
policies that would be required to
achieve that it is possible and in order
to achieve it it would require fewer
working hours per person so there would
be more leisure time that more leisure
time could be used to interact with
family and friends and improve social
capital it would it would involve a
stabilization of population and an
investment shifting away from
consumption goods and towards public
goods so we need to shift away from
fossil fuels and towards renewable
energy we need to have more efficient
transportation systems etc there's a
long list there but it also involves
investing in our our human capital
infrastructure so investing in education
investing in healthcare
investing in population stabilization
that would be in reducing the gap in
income and invest in rewarding people
for for participating in in their in
their societies and their communities I
think we're going to need everyone to
change the world not just people from
environmental schools but I think we
need we need also to change the minds
and the approach and the vision of
people you know that are studying in MBA
programs and and and all across the
whole spectrum in in academia and I
think that's one of the problems itself
is the isolation of the different
academic disciplines and the lack of
sort of cross of dialogue so you know
how do we overcome that that constraint
in
academia transcending disciplinary
boundaries I think is a real is real key
now what that's one thing that I think
environmental schools can lead the way
and and are very much doing that so it's
not so much the environment as a
specific discipline of study but as a
way to bridge across you know all of the
various aspects of human knowledge and
pull pull all that together and get this
discussion and dialogue going to
actually solve problems for more
information on the visions of a
sustainable world project please visit
environment yale.edu forward slash
visions